uh so we're going to um open up today's
executive session for the house
committee on Election law um
representative qu will youe please lead
us in the pledge real
quick okay welcome everyone um there is
nothing scarier for Halloween than a
meeting of the house Committee of
election law um that's my one trick-or
treat joke for the day um after speaking
with both leaders of the respective
caucuses it appears that both caucuses
need a little more time to confer with
each other so uh I will be recessing for
uh representative L you give us 20
minutes we'll be recessing for 20
minutes so we will reconvene at 10:20
thank
you
up and immediately recess for another
three minutes uh my friends from the
Democratic caucus I believe your uh
ranking member is looking for you
outside so we will reconvene at 10:24
for
on the fly but I'll let you a look here
all right um so these are the Motions
that I have and we're going to
highlighted stuff first all right so
okay um definitely not running behind
today definitely on schedule uh
everything is totally organized uh ready
to go okay so we are going to uh
reconvene the executive session for the
house election law committee
uh we're going to open up the executive
session on House Bill 333 FN relative to
changing the date of the state primary
election and adding a runoff election if
necessary representative prud Hol
O'Brien is rep is recognized for a
motion
um I'm
sorry
um
I've got this amendment here is that
what you're disc no I believe we're
doing a we're doing oh I'm sorry let me
back up real fast um the way we're going
to do the bills today is first thing
we're going to try to do is go through
things that I think are going to be
unanimous um or are
immovable um so we won't be going in the
order as listed on there um we're going
to go people need to pay attention but
we're going to go through the things
that I imagine we have debated furiously
before um and and are not going to move
on so it's obviously up to the committee
if they want to change but hav been
doing this now for 3 years I think I
know how things are going to shck out so
we are on HB 333 which uh are you now
ready for to be recognized
representative prud O'Brien uh yes I um
move to itl 33 there's a motion for any
speaking to legislate representative
weie is seconding that motion I am is
there any discussion on the
bill uh I think that we're going to get
to this subject of the State primary
election and some other bills that we
have today so that is uh why I think we
can ital this it's wise to do so there
any further discussion on the bill
hearing none uh the clerk will call the
role uh please remember members to uh
turn your microphones on and then off um
so that we can for those watching at
home can have the vote
recorded representative
B
yes representative Pome O'Brien
yes representative quy
yes representative Ankerberg
yes representative
Burnham
yes representative warry yes
representative wood
yes representative Osborne yes
representative cutab
yes representative Lane yes
representative Ward
yes representative hamr yes
representative Hamlet
yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay
yes representative Brennan
yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rafter yes representative Barry chair
votes
yes and with that uh HB 333 will be
reported out of committee as inexpedient
to legislate 20 and0 is there any
objection to it being placed onto the
consent calendar hearing no objection
representative PR O'Brien can you please
take care of the committee report thank
you um we'll do some quick other
business real fast I should have pointed
out uh welcome Representatives rafter
Osborne and cab uh to election law I'm
sorry I should have started off with
that that was extraordinarily rude so um
welcome um we are back to 1010 so uh I
can stop being confused when I say
something's going to be 10 10 and we
only have 18 committee members um okay
we are I'm going to close the House
Executive session on HB 333 and open up
the house executive session on House
Bill
387 uh permitting election ballots to be
viewed pursuant to a right to no request
uh representative Lane you are
recognized for a motion um I move to itl
uh House Bill 387 is there a
second representative Ward seconds is
there any discussion on the
bill um the the bill is before us um was
fraught with some problems and uh we
couldn't reach consensus on any changes
so as a result we're going to itl it and
uh if the people want to bring it back
next time please do thank you y and and
I do believe there is a LSR that covers
this subject so we will eagerly await
that as it works its way through the
legislative process representative Grill
I'm sorry you were wishing to speak oh
okay are there any further discussion on
House Bill
387 hearing none the clerk will call the
role representative bom
yes representative prome O'Brien
yes representative quae
yes representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative cutab yes representative
Lane
yes representative Ward yes
representative HR yes representative
Hamet
yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes represent Grill yes
representative Howard
yes representative rafter yes
representative Barry a chair votes yes
um with that house bill 387 will be
reported out as inexpedient to legislate
20 to0 is there any objection to it
being placed on the consent calendar
hearing no objection um representative
Lane will you be able to handle the
committee report or assign it to a
member of your caucus to handle yes
thank you um with that I will be closing
the executive session on House Bill 387
and opening the executive session on
House Bill
395 relative to the voter's guide for
Constitutional
Amendments is there a motion on House
Bill 395 representative Lane you are
recognized for a motion um thank you I
move to itl uh HB 395 is there a
second second representative bone
seconds is there any discussion on House
Bill
395 representative Lane you're
recognized um thank you um I think there
was support for this from both parties
the uh problem was that we could not
reach consensus on who would draft the
Constitutional Amendment so um we've
spoken to the uh major sponsors and have
asked and promised that we'll work to
resolve this hopefully and uh bring it
back again next year thank you further
discussion on on the bill hearing no
discussion the clerk will call the role
for House Bill 395 representative B
yes representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative quae yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative cutab
yes representative Lane yes
representative Ward
yes representative hamr yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Mirad yes representative Bay
yes representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rafter yes
representative Barry chair votes yes um
with that house bill 395 will be
reported out 20 to Z as inexpedient to
legislate uh is there any objection to
House Bill
395 being placed onto the consent
calendar hearing none House Bill 395
will be placed onto the consent talend
and I will close the executive session
on House Bill 395 uh and I'm guess
representative Lane you to be recognized
um yes thanks um do you uh want to do a
report on that uh you know you took the
last one I'll take this one
okay thank you and um okay so so
everybody know the chair has to write
the reports if there's no assigned one
anyway so either thank you
representative lane from saving me for
myself and then resigning the work to
myself anyways because that's how I roll
um all right and let's end our 20
Ventures and let's open up the house
bill on uh Senate
bill6 uh fiscal note relative to voter
registration and verification of voter
identity representative katab you are
recognized for a motion uh SB I'm sorry
sb15 6 relative to voter registration
and verification of voter identity I
move itl repres representative katab
moved Senate Bill 156 to in speak to
legislate is there a
second I'll second representative
Burnham SE second excuse me is there any
discussion on the
bill hearing none the clerk will call
the
role representative boom
yes representative prome O'Brien
yes representative quy yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative cutab yes representative
Lane
yes the bill 156 yes okay oh excellent
um representative Ward
yes representative
hamr yes representative Hamlet yes
representative Mirad
yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rafter yes
Barry uh the chair votes yes and um with
that when we have future discussions
about 1010 we'll be clarify what that
means no no you'll be yes no I'll be no
uh all right so that's awesome SP 1556
will be reported out as inexpedient to
legislate 20 to Z uh is there any
objection to it being placed on the
consent calendar hearing none I will
take my win and go home um uh
representative katab will you please
write the committee report for that it
would be my pleasure all right all right
and I will close the executive session
on SB
156 um and I will open up the executive
session on Senate Bill 158 relative to
absentee ballot outer envelopes
representative Wei is recognized for a
motion I itl uh there's a motion of
inexpedient to legislate is there a
second out second representative wood
seconds is there any discussion on the
motion of inexpedient to legislate to
Senate Bill 158
hearing oh I'm sorry hearing none the
clerk will call the
role representative B
yes representative pom O'Brien yes
representative qua yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative vernham
yes representative wary yes
representative wood yes representative
Osborne yes representative cob yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative hamr yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Mirad representative
Mirad
yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes
representative Raptor yes representative
Barry chair votes yes um all right once
again discuss what 101 means um Senate
Bill 158 will be reported out as
inexpedient to legislate um is there any
objection to it being placed on the
consent calendar hearing none
representative weie will you please take
care of the committee report for the
committee pleasure thank you and with
that I will close the executive session
on Senate Bill 158 and now let let's get
into the
Wheats okay um where do we want to go
from here let's do I'm sorry represent
Lane um have did we put HB 333 on
consent I believe that we did but if you
okay um yep I believe everything has
gone on the consent calendar which I am
Overjoyed about um because it means less
speeches on the floor yeah hopefully put
that caveat hopefully um okay let's
start off I tell you what
um let's start off with Senate
Bill uh
243 require House Bill excuse me House
Bill 243 requiring the tabulation of
votes in elections to be done in public
so if the members want to get that in
front of them we'll wait through the
Jeopardy music um okay with that um we
will I'm opening up the house executive
session on House Bill 243 requiring the
tabulation of votes in elections to be
done in public representative katab is
recognized for a motion thank you Mr
chairman I move OT
otpa
um or should I give the amendment number
now or after so what we're going to do
here is you're going to I believe the
representative wants to make a motion
for ought to pass and then I believe the
representative wants to wait for a
second and then I believe the
representative wants to bring forward an
amendment would you like to make a
motion of ought to pass to pass yes
please excellent is there a second I
second that seconded repres are there
any amendments that any the members like
to bring
forward thank you Mr chairman I moved uh
to bring forward Amendment
2023-24 okay um we are on discussion of
the amendment let's give everybody a
second does every member have the
amendment in front of
them and I say that because I don't know
if I do where is
it there we go thank you I think I gave
all right so we are on discussion of
Amendment
2023-24 um representative katav you're
recognized to speak to your Amendment
thank you Mr chairman so I think this is
another bill that we could probably all
agree on we need to make sure that our
elections are accurate it was intended
to already do this if you look in the
election manual however the RSA on it
wasn't clear and so this is the exact
tabulation definition that came out of
the election ual and I know that there
had been a little bit of concern about
not being clear um that the central
polling location counting could also
still happen and so that was explicitly
put into this me uh amendment that the
final results of an election in a
polling place or at the central polling
location as provided in RSA
65959 and I did want to point out uh I
was there in wiam at the primary and
afterwards our vote was was ret
tabulated
incorrectly and uh when the announcement
came out it was actually post the period
where you could even request a recount
and thankfully the the other candidate
who had already requested a recount
didn't cancel the recount otherwise we
wouldn't have known that it was wrong so
I think it's really important that we do
this uh especially you know when we're
talking about primaries in order to
request a recount you can only request a
recount of the votes within 10 votes or
one and a half %c and I know in Windam I
4% of my votes were were hand count
votes so uh we we really just want to
make sure that the the elections uh are
accurate and they've already had a great
way of of counting for us in public and
so now they'll just be doing the final
tabulation for us right there so thank
you okay is there a further discussion
on the
amendment yes um yes representative
Hamlet thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative
um so my question is the the tape is is
it still unofficial that's an it's an
unofficial result
so um why should that be
posted for the public to view if if it's
an unofficial result because the the
handc count votes and the and the you
know absentee ballot some of the some of
the votes haven't been included in that
final
tabulation I I can I can answer it for
the% if you'd like um so this is a this
last provision is my provision um this
transparency as you know I've been after
this for some time um the reality is so
for there's multiple reasons why to
answer your question um it is The
Unofficial it's not the final um it is
The Unofficial it is not the final um it
is only official for that it's not
official it's only posted for that
machine right so the the issue at hand
is
twofold there is is multiple ways in
which towns and cities are handling
these tapes and countings right so some
cities and towns uh immediately after
the polls of closed and the last ballot
has been cast they immediately print the
summary tapes and they immediately read
The Unofficial tape results I really
like that um that makes life a lot
easier for everybody awaiting those
results because most of our elections
are not decided um by a small margin
most of them are one way or the other um
the other concern is that with the
centralized counting you are packing up
these machines they are going out of
sight they are going into a car they are
being transported they are being
unloaded somewhere else and then they
are being run somewhere else um and that
invites speculation um I'm actually
surprised nobody has raised that as
speculation yet um but it does just
invite it the machine is out of sight
for a period of time so it's a twofer um
number one is we are going to get the
results for let's call it 80% of New
Hampshire's elections um within 30
minutes of the respective ballot closing
and number two is we are going to um
preemptively stop uh speculation being
raised about what happened when the
machine was unplugged and moved um so
does that sufficiently answer the
question well I have a follow-up
question so I should should it not be
clarified in in this amendment
that you know announcing the the total
Vote or posting the the total votes is
the unofficial results so it's it's not
necessary because they're not posted as
the official results and some like I
said some cities and towns are already
doing this so if
they're my statement to representative
would be if you're concerned about the
confusion you should probably be
concerned the confusion is already
occurring so it hasn't been a problem
for my understanding is most cities and
towns actually do it like this um we're
just kind of bringing everybody up
online um the the example I always give
is Salem New Hampshire has I think five
voting location
um maybe three whatever they have more
than one um and they do a centralized
counting so what Salem does is they pick
up all their machines they move them all
to a centralized counting location where
it all happens kind of in secret um and
then they release their results at about
1:00 in the
morning totally unnecessary for Salem
New Hampshire um if you know the makeup
of that town that election goes One Way
normally um totally unnecessary and we
don't need to be waiting till 1:00 in
the morning to get those results um so
yes it is unofficial there's nothing
that's going to be posted that says
these are the official counts uh the
laws about the return of votes still all
stays the same um but for those
Representatives looking to go home
whether or not knowing they've won or
lost an election night uh they won't
need to wait till 10 or 11 or in my case
when I used to represent Manchester and
Lichfield I had to wait till 1:00 in the
morning to find out that I had won my
election um for literally no Reas reason
I won by 800 votes it wasn't close um so
we're trying to there there's really no
reason in New Hampshire we can't have
80% of our results by 8:30 at night um
in this state everything else it's just
it's going to be uniform it's going to
be better and I I guess uh you know
trust but verify me on this uh you're
you're going to like this a lot
better okay thank you uh representative
Brennan thank you Mr chair um couple of
things have been I just want to draw
attention to um I
appreciate the um feeling of impatience
when we have to wait for election
results and as a candidate I know um it
is you know we're on pins and needles
waiting for those results I can agree
with what you're saying that it's it's
hard to wait um but is it not important
or more important to have accurate final
results released and does it not create
more speculation if you release
unofficial results um ahead of those
final
results I'm just saying so it's already
happening most towns and cities are
already doing this so this just brings
all the other towns who kind of refuse
to do their work in public and quickly
um up to spec with what the other towns
are doing um my counter punt counter
punch that would be if the tape comes
out and it says it's close you're going
to hang around for the official results
if the tape comes out and it's a blowout
you're either going to go celebrate or
Drown Your Sorrows um but there's no you
know we're not there's going to be no
misrepresentation that this is a
official final result this these tapes
are going to be made public anyways um
because they are public documents
they're going to made public anyways the
question is is when are they going to be
made public public are they going to be
made public 30 minutes after the last
ballot is run through the machine or are
they going to be made public at 1:00 in
the morning um either way the different
components of this bill are going to be
made the different components that go
into the tabulation of the votes for the
return of votes for the secretary state
is made public um and just following up
on my colleague um representative Hamlet
should it not then say in here that
these are unofficial results to make it
clear if we're putting this type of
language into law
so it my my Counterpoint to that would
be if they're already doing it we don't
already require that they already say
this is just the machines only and
that's what the language reads is the
long tape the long report tape it
doesn't say the official results it
doesn't say the unofficial results it
says it is a posting of the tape um and
it's by a machine so it's going to be
you're going to see four different tapes
or however many machines are at the
location are going to be posted and
you're still going to have to do math um
but you're going to know what's going on
um you know any the concerns to not
posting
these the concern to not posting these
tapes it's already happening over half
of our locations that I'm aware of are
already posting these tapes and already
reading them um and people are already
hanging around 15 minutes after the
polls close with their writing down the
tape results um it's just why not make
it uniform across the
board um different municipalities do
things differently it's local control
and we do have an issue or I have an
issue with the 30 minute time frame
there are many times when the tabulation
of results um takes longer than 30
minutes it is not just the tape that
reports out the results it is the
election volunteers who are counting
hand counting wrin votes and so if you
only are doing the tape within that 30
minute time frame you are potentially
missing out on many votes that could be
hand counted as wenss that might affect
the outcome of the election and therei
therefore be misleading the candidates
or anyone who might be reading that tape
only and not waiting for the final
results after the tabulation occurs by
the
volunteers who are counting the
writings correct and that I'll second
represent kab and that would be the
decision of the candidate not to around
to hear
that are you not making it more
difficult for election workers who um
you know oftentimes are there for many
hours and who now are on a time crunch
of 30 minutes what happens what is the
result if a uh election worker election
officials does not post this within 30
minutes is there a penalty for that or a
consequence there is Not By Design and
there are many pieces of election law
and election procedure that do not hold
a penalty for not following them this
would be one of them um but that's and
that's okay and to answer your question
about are you burdening them the
printing of the tapes Takes a Minute it
takes one minute and they are doing it
anyways they have to print the tapes
anyways to do their tabulation of votes
so they print the tapes after the last
ballot is through not when polls close
after the last ballot is through because
sometimes it voting is occurring after
the polls have closed so it's after the
last ballot is thow through then they
have 30 minutes
to go over and click
print and then they have 30 minutes to
walk over and put a piece of Scotch tape
on the tape and put it on the
door and how does this impact the many
municipalities that are hand count only
it doesn't affect them at all so then we
still have a difference uh we are not
doing something Universal that would
apply to all municipalities only those
who have um ballot counting devices so
the claim that this would make it
Universal or um you know apply to
everyone and that you're trying to solve
an issue where there are towns doing
this now towns that are not doing it and
you're trying to make it equal among
those it's still not equal because you
still have hand count towns that are not
affected by this and therefore it is not
a universal rule correct and I will end
our back and forth with this which is it
universally applies to every town which
has chosen to use a machine
representative katab
so I just wanted to State I did talk to
a a couple of the clerks yesterday who
do currently already do this and they
said when they post them up they just
let people know these are the tape
readouts only these are not official
results they make it very clear and one
of the clerks said you know we'll even
point out like there's still this big
stack of of hand count votes so the
results very well may change and they
just make it clear to everybody that's
there and I do want to say like it is
very clear that it's only if RSA 659752
applies which is the um enabling
legislation that allows the towns to use
the machines and I think what R Barry or
chairman Barry was trying to say was
that you know for the towns that are
using these machines for them to all be
doing it the same way that way we don't
have some doing it one way and some
doing it another it's just opening up
transparency that's
all thank you Mr chair also it doesn't
affect all those things that have to be
handc counted they can go on till four
o'clock in the morning like I've done
um but just for the tape for those
people running for office they now can
hey I can go home now because I was out
all day uh so but if I'm close if
there's only maybe 20 votes between me
and my opponent yeah I'd better stay
until to or get somebody to phone me uh
and in our town well in Ros Berry's
District which includes litfield and two
Wards in Manchester Manchester does
this the current moderator in litfield
doeses not so he had to wait for
litfield to vote to see if he won the
problem is the previous moderator used
to do it and then we got new moderator
he wouldn't do it until the final vote
was counted so so yeah this way I'd like
it because hey let's see if I can go
home now you know main thing but yeah
let's see and if I'm won by 300 votes
then I know
I won
yeah okay further discussion on the bill
Amendment excuse me first the amendment
excuse me representative
Lane thank you I guess I'm
still um when I read line six the new
language are we not still requiring when
they bring them together as they do in
many of the
cities that that be done in
public R kab thank you Mr Mr chairman
thank you for the question so this um no
this would be if you
are this is when you're adding the
actual results together if you're doing
them either at the individual polling
place or at the central polling location
this isn't requiring for the towns like
NASA that do them all at individual
locations this is the aggregation just
of the results from the long report and
the Hand count so you're not this isn't
adding Ward results together
I try to put the statue in there just to
be really clear that right and I that
that's still absolutely lot and I took
this wording out of the election manual
and so there's another sentence which
then talks about the tabulating of
the you know different polling location
results and that's explicitly not in
here because to your concern about um
you know that may be difficult for
certain towns so uh so piggy back on
that res talk you took this language out
of the C law manual correct so this is
what's already supposed to be currently
being
done thank you okay representative
brenon thank you I wonder if this is
something that really requires a law and
I wonder if perhaps the Secretary of
State might as he's conducting trainings
with our election officials throughout
the state perhaps he might suggest to
them that it is not illegal to post the
tape is that correct it is not in law
that um that municipalities cannot post
the tape I I don't believe there
anything posting about the tapes um so I
I just I wonder if this is really a
necessary law or if it is perhaps just
something that could be suggested by the
Secretary of State to election officials
rather than putting them on the clock of
the 30
minutes um
I just worry that this might create more
problems than it's trying to solve and
perhaps a suggestion rather than a law
would resolve the issue that um you're
trying to solve representative
wey uh thank you chairman uh the
Secretary of State's office has
repeatedly stated that the training that
is provided is poorly attended and that
um there's
uh I think there would be problems with
counting on the training and the
compliance
to
overcome
um this deficiency and knowledge by
moderators and clerks and so forth I
they're they're not attending the
training now and if we're expecting
training to cover up a gap in in the
rsas then I I think we're counting on
too much to be covered by the
training sorry representative Brennan
thank you um it's my understanding that
the secretary of state is able to send
out memos and emails to moderators and
town clerks and perhaps would consider
writing an email or memo saying that it
is perfectly okay to post the tape
following an election and a law would
not be necessary to make that so
thank you my my counter punch to that
would be uh I don't like giving away our
policymaking to an executive um so I
that is a personal philosophical view um
I do if you've ever followed me I rail
on the bureaucracy creating rules um all
the time because that is our job um so I
I view that um respectfully as a
dereliction of Duty it is our job to
write the policies it is not the job of
the executive or the
bureaucrats all right with that I think
we've uh we've all probably spoken our
piece on representative Lane you like
like to jump in on this uniting
conversation I would uh like to ask for
a five to 10 minute
recess okay
um yep that's fine uh because I I am
getting blown up by my work so it's
perfect um let's recess for uh can we
reconvene at
11:08 okay thank you uh we'll reconvene
11:08
on Amendment 2023
h238 2023
2384 amendment to House Bill 243 and I
will immediately recess the um uh
Amendment uh I believe there's something
going to go to
OS uh to address changes um so we will
we will I'm going to recess the
amendment and I'm now I'm going to
recess the actual underlying bill and we
will move on to whatever the next uh
debate will be which let's decide I
don't know what what do you think Madam
clerk
um you want to do this portal let's do
the portal let's do the portal sure all
right um everybody's here for the portal
right um how all right so I'm going to
open up the house executive session on
House
Bill 463 FN relative to the
establishment of an election information
portal I'm going to repres recognize
representative Hamlet for a
motion I'm sorry not represent Hamlet um
represent Lane I apologize
representative Lane for a
motion Oh I thought are we not ready on
that all right so my mistake we will
recess
uh it's one of those days we will recess
House Bill 463 of the establishment of
an elect information portal we will come
back to that bad boy um let's just get
this out of the way um I will open up uh
the executive session on House Bill 476
enabling the Secretary of State to
conduct a second recount after an
election I will recognize myself for an
OP to pass motion is somebody going to
be very nice and second me thank you
representative B who is second me um I
would like to uh the bill is open for
amendments was there an amendments I'd
like yes I'd like to recognize myself to
sub for an amendment um I going to
submit Amendment 2023
2379 H um which is an amendment to House
Bill
476 okay uh and then I will speak to my
Amendment um
so this stems from the recount
of
um um Manchester Ward 6 in which a stack
of votes was missed during the recount
and it changed the outcome of the
election uh there was then an ensuing
legal battle um to count all of the
votes U and I don't want to open up the
old wound on that um but it was not an
inexpensive legal battle for the
prevailing side um and so what I am
seeking to do is
address this so it doesn't have to go
back to court again um and I do know
that the argument is going to be made
made that after the victory in court um
estab a precedent has been established
and all that um but the reality is is
anything can be taken to court our
current law does say no second recount
um so either way if this situation
happens again where it is objectively
determined that and that's not my take
on it that was the Court's take on it um
that is objectively determined that not
all the ballots were counted um it
doesn't stop someone from attempting to
stop the secretary of state from doing
that in court again so what I have done
is drafted an amendment only uh drafted
a bill only to state general elections
so nothing else just state general
elections which says that if the recount
shows that the outcome of the election
has changed which basically means the
the winner is no longer the winner and
there is a new winner right so not the
results change so the the number of
votes didn't change like the number of
votes that always changes in a recount
um but the actual winner changes um then
there shall be a second recount so so
the my rationale behind this is if the
outcome changes if there are new winners
both sides are going to put a lot of
scrutiny on the second and what is
labeled the final recount so that gives
both sides an opportunity maybe they
weren't fully engaged I don't know or
maybe there was a dispute um but it
allows both sides to bring their
resources to Bear during a required
second recount versus going to the court
um and begging for a second recount um
this you know probably you know if you
look at the number of Elections that
changed outcomes this year I think this
would have only applied to three um in
total um so we're not adding a whole
bunch of new recounts um it's not after
speaking with Secretary of State's
office they had concerns my original
Bill had it at the discretion of the
Secretary of State the Secretary of
State um informed me that he didn't want
the discretion um and I tended to agree
with him on that which is we don't want
um accusations flying that the Secretary
of State should or should not have
called for a second recount so the idea
here is we are going to get it right uh
it does not go on in perpetuity um so if
that second recount that's it that's it
it's over after the second recount but
if the winner changes there shall be
another counting to make sure that the
change that was determined by the
recount was accurate and it's the final
one
um so that's my that's what my Amendment
does um and I said I'm I'm more than
happy to explain uh my experience I do
represent Manchester Ward 6 although it
was not my election um and I can say it
was a very um not awesome experience so
with that are there other comments on
the on house Amendment 2023
[Music]
23798 hearing none um are hearing none
um well we're missing one Republican and
one Democrat so
um the no we're missing one in one
missing Howard and well R Mir we know
you're a closet Republican that's okay
um um work it's going to go great in
your primary and Handover uh hope
somebody clips that um I'm I'm
comfortable I'm comfortable calling the
role since we're uh in parody in our
absences so the clerk will call the
sorry represent thank you I hate to be
we did not discuss this in caucus
because we didn't have the amendment in
front of us so would you like me to
recess this vote that I'm about to take
and and definitely didn't call yes okay
I will definitely did not call the role
the clerk didn't call anything so we
will recess the house Amendment uh 2023
23978 and I will recess the underlying
Bill and we'll see if there's something
we can vote on Mr chair and I'm sorry I
what time is the catered lunch arriving
yes good luck I was hoping to get out by
lunch that dream has died yeah that
dream the candy is was unrealistic dream
but um I have I do not have from OS um
the amendment for for for the portal for
the portal okay so we won't go there and
um well let's dispense
447 yeah uh let's you have the amendment
for that right we do have that okay so
we're going to Recess Recess um
Amendment uh House Bill
476 and we will open up uh the executive
session on House Bill 447 FN relative to
the purchase of election equipment uh
representative Wei you are recognized
for a
motion click on your microphone for me
representative thank you thank you um
thank you Mr chair
um I believe we uh ought to pass this
yes excellent there is a motion of ought
to pass on house B 447 FN is there a
second representative wood oh second
seconds are there any amendments to
House Bill 447
FN representative Lane you are
recognized to introduce your amendment I
would like to introduce uh Amendment
2023 d23
66h right um every committee have that
amendment I I handed them out and I have
extras if anybody needs them I will take
I will take your extras because per
usual my desk has exploded um okay so I
will take their extra I have read your
Amendment for what it's worth I do like
it I just can't bring fiscal fiscal
copies all right representative Lane you
recognize to speak to um Amendment 2023
23668 right so um what this bill does is
give the Secretary of State the
authorization to use the money in an
equitable way um up to um 3 million uh
over three years so there's a Sunset and
um it the secretary of state would set
up um a way to do this again equitably
um if if he needs to use the if he so
chooses to do and um for those of us who
um the Hava funds are funds that came in
for help America vot vot um there's an
obligation in our existing statute um I
think to keep 12 times the money right
now there's that would be around if I
don't quote me on the numbers but
there's around three million there that
that is an excess of what um has to be
there under existing statute this gives
the Secretary of State the ability to
use that for specifically for the voting
election voting
machines further discussion on the amend
Amendment all right um I am very
thankful this amendments come forward as
you know I am a um a big proponent of
getting this done um I know that there
was uh support on U my my um cuses in to
um make these funds less discretionary
so I think this vote might surprise us
uh with that um the clerk will call the
role on um adopting Amendment 2023 2366
H to house 447 FN thank you madam clerk
here representative bone yes
representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative qua yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative
cutab uh representative Lane
yes representative Ward
yes representative hamr
yes representative Hamlet yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard still not here um representative
Rapter yes and representative Barry
chair votes yes um and with that house
uh Amendment 20
I'm about to read the wrong Amendment um
uh 2023 2366 H is adopted to house
before 47 uh I'm blinking on my do we
need a new motion now for otpa yes so
representative Lane you're recognized
for a motion um I move that we pass um
HB um 447 FN um s otpa and I will second
that motion
um and is there any discussion on on the
bill as
amended hearing none um the clerk will
call the role and we're back fully full
back to 1010
wow um representative
Bo yes I'm sorry hold on we're going to
pause the voting my assist my researcher
is flagging me like I did something
wrong which I probably
did oh I'm sorry yes representative Wy
can you please withdraw your OTP
motion I would like to withdraw my OTP
motion thank you it withdrawn and we
will go back to the otpa vote
representative B you were
called
yes representative prome O'Brien yes
representative quy yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
Representative cutab
no representative
Lane
yes representative Ward yes
representative HR yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rapor yes representative
chair votes yes 19 to1 with that it's 19
to1 um representa katab do you uh object
to this going onto the consent calendar
I do not you do not okay with that um I
will take care of the committee report
um and um there will be it'll be on
consent calendar which Whoever thought
that would have happened so just
election law just full of surprises
today I'm going to close the um
executive session on House Bill 447
reported out as
otpa hold on I got fre rhyme notes
191 um and then oops and there goes my
computer Okay so we've done that
one you guys need to
caucus um okay I think everything else
is going to require the two parties to
because what we have left here is
HB um 115 which is with discussions on
amendments intertwined with HB 345 and
HB
350 um giving deference to in respect to
the respective caucuses I know they want
to meet one more time and discuss that
um also it sounds like there's a need to
caucus on for the respective parties on
hp16 um and HB
243 and we are are still awaiting an
amendment for HB
463 so that puts us in this situation of
we're near
lunch
um so I think representative Lane um
would you be okay if we just broke for
lunch and the various teams can discuss
over lunch with their own caucuses um
because I don't think we're going to get
this done in time um and then you know
how I feel about lunch yes do um so
that's what we will do we will recess
until um Call of the chair which will be
at
12 let it 45 or 30 an hour an hour and
15 I have a one o'clock meeting but I
can handle it's okay all right we'll do
a 12:30 um because I can always extend
it so the we will stand in recess until
12:30 um for prospective caucuses and
some much needed lunch and most
importantly to not hear my voice anymore
all right I will see you guys back at
12:30
35 so I'm going to reopen um the
executive session for the house election
law committee um we're going to
reopen the executive session on House
Bill
476 um enabling Secretary of State to
conduct a second recount after an
election um discussion was on the
amendment so we are going to go back
onto the amendment um I believe I had
spoken my piece um is there any other
discussion on the amendment we're
talking about Amendment 2023 230 2379
H any further discussion on the
amendment um hearing no discussion um
representative Lane would you objectif I
I called the role without representative
Hamlet being
present she's at OS I
believe do you believe the outcome will
change with her presence okay so without
objection I will I mean I can call it
when I want I'm just trying to be nice
all right uh so we will the clerk will
call the role for Amendment 2023 2379 H
to House Bill
476 representative B
yes representative prome O'Brien yes
representative quae yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
lean yes representative Ward yes
representative hamr yes representative
Hamlet representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan
yes representative Grill yes should I
call her name I'm sorry this is out of
order uh we need to finish this vote um
but I I read the wrong amendment number
so we're going to have to finish this
vote I'm
sorry I I will I will correct my
error should I call
and she was not here so no you can okay
um representative Howard yes
representative rafter yes represented
very yes and now I'm going to
immediately un oh no no I am on the
right one I'm sorry I am I am
discombobulated that was the right vote
we took the right vote I'm sorry I'm I'm
already on to the next bill I'm already
on to the next bill my brain is I got a
lot of things going on today so we are
good there as unanimous 190 uh house uh
so um Amendment 2023 h23 79h has been
added to house bu 4761 19
to0 um the motion is now oop pass as
amended um is there discussion on the
bill as
amended hearing no discussion we are
going I'm going going the cler call the
role for House Bill 476 as amended with
HB 2023 2379 H just so everybody at home
is do we need a second for otpa uh I
don't believe we do but just in case
we'll copy it over from whoever it was
earlier which was
representative
B um no was you it was I know I I made
the OTP you're doing you're you're
you're very generously doing your second
again all right oh yes yes um okay uh
the clerk will call the role on House
Bill 4 uh
476 as amended with Amendment 2023 2379
H representative Bo yes representative
Pome O'Brien yes representative quy yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative hamr yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Mirad yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard yes representative rter yes
representative Barry chair votes yes
okay and with that um House Bill 476
will be reported out as O A to pass as
amended once again with 2023 2379 H uh I
will take care of the committee report
because I fumbled the middle of that
vote and that's a good Penance for that
um so with that we will go
oh yes a consent does anybody have any
objection to consent calendar on
that no hearing no objection we'll go on
to consent calendar and I appreciate the
committee's Indulgence and my
confusion um next up we will do that was
this one hold on scratched out the wrong
bill um there it is uh we will open up
uh we will re we will reopen the
executive session for House Bill uh 243
um we were on discussion as the
amendment um so we do need to dispense
with the original Amendment before we
can take up what I believe will be a new
Amendment um so we were on this is where
my confusion came from last time for
those paying attention we were on
Amendment um excuse me
2384 um so we need to if we are to take
up another amendment we first must
dispense with this amendment or I guess
you can withdraw the motion all right
the motion is withdrawn is there another
amendment representative katab you're
recognized I move Amendment 2023
d2394 um Sarah second representative
Howard seconds thank you representative
Howard lovely day of bipartisanship here
in election law um representative katab
would you like to speak to your
Amendment this was just changed in the
posting of the tapes U requirement to
instead of within 30 minutes to within
minutes okay is there any other further
discussion on the new
Amendment yes representative Brennan
thank you Mr chair
um we have not had a public hearing on
this so we have not heard opinions from
town clerks um and moderators who may
have something to say about this and so
uh I do have still some concerns about
it although I am very much appreciative
of the extension from 30 minutes to 60
Minutes um I will not be voting in favor
of this thank you okay further
discussion on the
amendment here yep representative I'm
sorry prudo mban thank you I will be
voting for this I think this is a good
bill um and I have heard from some Town
clerks um that the 60 Minutes is is
satisfactory so I will be voting for it
further disc on the
amendment hearing none the clerk will
call the role to Amendment
2394 representative
B yes representative predom O'Brien yes
representative quy yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative hyr yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Mirad yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan
no representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
Rapter yes representative Barry chair
votes yes um with that the amendment is
adopted 19 to1 we are now on to
discussion on the bill as amended the
motion is now octop passed as amended um
is there discussion on the bill as
amended hearing oh yes representative
bone no oh I apologize hearing no
discussion um the clerk will call the
role to House Bill
243 as amended by Amendment uh 20 2023
23 uh
94h representative boom yes
representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative qua yes representative
Ankerberg
yes sorry what was
that representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative HR yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan no representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rapor yes representative Barry the chair
votes yes and with that house bill 243
will be reported out as ought to pass as
amended 19 to1 um is there an objection
to the consent calendar hearing no
objection it will be placed on consent
calendar um representative K oh actually
representative katab could you do the
um uh committee report on this I'd be
honored thank you all right and with
that I will close the executive session
on House Bill
243 uh I will open up um the executive
session on House Bill
116 relative to fees and primary
petitions required for primary ballot
access uh I will move the bill as ought
to pass is there a
second representative B second I do have
an amendment for the committee um which
I know there it is um n that's the wrong
Amendment the old Amendment let me give
you guys the committee number here it is
it is I am going to move Amendment 2023
81h um I need a second on this right um
represent B can you give me a second
thank you okay we are now on discussion
on Amendment 2023 H 2023 2381 a lot of
2023 202 2023 23 81h uh to houseb 116
and I'll speak to it real fast um so
this is very simple um it get gets rid
of any changing of the existing petition
requirements for third party or major
party we got a lot of push back on that
so the current petition requirements for
ballot access stay exactly as they are
right now um and then it increases the
filing fees for United States Senate and
United States Congress um from $100 to
$2,500 and $50 to $1,250 respectively
and eliminates the filing fee for state
representative so it takes it from a
grand total of $2 from a grand total of
$0 um and I'm happy to explain why um so
for state representative the I do not
care what the the municipal Association
says there is zero chance that they are
processing a $2 transaction and not
losing money on it um they can't there
is no way they can account for that
$2 and not net lose $2 um so that's why
that changed um $2 is you can't even get
a Coke for that anymore to restaurant so
just get get rid of that um and then
with a discussion amongst members it
seemed like uh that was going to be a
non-starter so I went for the other
stuff um which was changing the filing
fees for representative for Congress and
US Senate um the thought process being
here is um if you know $50 to file for
United States Congress to then go handle
a um what is it a $ 33 trillion budget
or something um you know it just it's
time to raise these so when these were
originally put in if you were to
extrapolate these out for inflation they
would be much higher than they are even
in this amendment um but just kind of
you know leaving people running for
serious office to having serious you
know I would I would make the statement
that that even 1250 is not necessarily a
serious resource but at least make it to
where it's not um makes it a little more
painful to file as a joke um so you can
still get on with your petition
signatures that stays exactly the same
ironically enough if you know the cost
of petition signature it costs much more
than
$1,250 to collect that many petition
signatures um but I view this as a very
reasonable um bump up um you know we
original bill was $10,000 and people
really gave a lot of push back on that
but I think this is a
um it's not even in the middle ground
it's like a happy bottom quarter uh
agreement to kind of keep things keep
keep things people putting their name on
the ballot are going to be more serious
about it when it's 1,250 bucks instead
of $100 which is probably less than some
Babs at tandies so um open up to I'm
obviously open up to more discussion on
the amendment um people can tell me why
I'm wrong and I'm cool with that
too yes representative Howard thank you
Mr chair and thank you fell
Representatives uh I I'm very against
this amendment because I still feel that
we should be allowing ballot access for
people especially when we have the cost
of uh running to be on the presidential
primary is only
$1,000 uh I understand the fact that
there are reasons why certain people uh
don't want others to run and why uh
making it more difficult for people to
access their party primaries uh would
allow for uh candidates of a more spefic
spefic choice but I don't think that's
necessarily what we should be doing even
if people are quote unquote joke
candidates they may be providing real uh
commentary on what's happening in our
state and I think that they should have
the opportunity to run for office uh at
a price tag that is less than that
thousand to run for
president further discussion on the
amendment ah representative Mirad I
can't this will be I'm sure en
lightninging well I just qu question do
you know how many frivolous candidates
uh races like the governorship are
eliciting uh governorship not so much
it's usually actually the federal
Offices that tends to attract the um uh
the far out theirs U you know it's not
once again it's not about limiting
somebody's ability to get their message
out they can still do that um nothing
stops them from doing that getting their
message out nothing stops them from
mounting a writing campaign or raising
12,
$1,250 um it's just a matter of there is
a cost to have someone on the ballot
there a cost the state con cures a cost
of that um this by the way even at 2500
does not cover those costs um but it at
least stops it to where we're more
serious about what we're doing um the
way things are going but um my
Counterpoint to representative Howard um
would be you know I have an amendment
that leaves the current fees in place
but only gets rid of the state
representative fee would you be in favor
of
that uh I would okay uh representative
BM in the in the last election I believe
for
cd2 Congress there were like I think
seven people signed up and effectively
there were only three people running
never ever saw the other four so there
is a problem of just people putting the
name on the ballot just like the
presidential one which is I mean maybe
next time I'll run for president for a
thousand bucks but yeah so there was
just people I put my name on the ballot
no further uh conversation about why I'm
wrong all right um hearing none the
clerk will call the role on the on
Amendment 2023 2381
H representative
bom yes representative Crome O'Brien yes
representative qua yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative cutab yes yes
representative Lane no representative
Ward no representative HR no
representative Hamlet no representative
mired no representative Bay no
representative Brennan no representative
Grill no representative Howard no
Representative rter no representative
Barry uh yes and with that the amendment
fails um good news I have another
amendment
um going to introduce Amendment 2023
2382 H which only changes the filing fee
for state representative from $2 to $0
because as stated earlier there is no
way that the town is processing a $2
transaction and not losing money on that
transaction um so uh can I get represent
would you give me a I'm move this can I
get a second on that and um oh and
represent Mirad gives me a second all
right uh discussion on the now stripped
down Amendment um do you you not I'm
sorry uh does somebody want to give does
everybody have a copy of it or is am I
just like holding it to
myself what's the number uh it is 2023
2382 h no okay I will pass it around I'm
sorry I thought I distributed it I guess
I was
wrong no 2020 it's for me not
representative venberg um it's 2023 82
so I'm sending it around right now I
apologize I thought I distributed to the
committee okay there was a second one
yes okay
surprise there's more coming there's
more coming I had 20 I had 25 copies
printed there's more
coming but you know what it
says it changes uh exactly two
characters it may be the smallest change
of any Amendment it changes two
characters of the of the existing
RSA all right does everybody now have a
copy of this massive massively complex
Amendment one more I tell you they can
have mine they
can it's it's okay send it down that's
that's fine they have
mine good yes yeah this might be my
crowning achievement if it if it becomes
adopted um okay so a as stated the only
thing this does is remove is take the
filing fee from 0 uh from $2 to $0
because the towns cannot process a $2
transaction um issue a receipt put it in
give it to the treasurer have the
treasurer account for it um they can't
do it uh I also have personal reasons of
uh at one point the city of Manchester
could not make change for me um and I
actually said can you take my 20 and
they said no you have to have $2 we
can't make change for you um so if you
don't think somebody's been turned away
because they had too much money it's a
it's a thing um so let's just get rid of
it because $2 doesn't buy you a Coke so
that's my pitch let's get rid of it
because $2 doesn't buy you a
coke uh discussion on the amendment repr
wasent of bone oh
sorry anyone berer all right uh with
that the clerk will call the role on um
Amendment 2023
2382 H to house bill um 116 FN because
there's a fiscal note because it reduces
the town coffers by
$2
throw in Stacks at the clerk's office uh
representative Bo yes representative
Pome O'Brien okay
yes representative quy yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative cutab yes representative
way
no representative Ward no representative
hamr
yes representative Hamlet
yes representative mired yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan
no representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes and representative Barry the
chair votes yes yes and I'm going to
need the count because that doesn't
happen much here 17 to3 1 the amendment
is adopted
17-3 um and what I think is maybe an
election law first um okay so with that
we are on discussion as of the bill as
amended the motion is ought to pass as
amended uh to House Bill
116 is there discussion on the bill as
amended okay hearing none the clerk will
call the role on House Bill 111 116 as
amended by Amendment I gave my Amendment
away 23 uh 2382
H representative Bo yes representative
Pome O'Brien yes representative qua yes
representative Ankerberg yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative kutab yes representative
Lane no
representative Ward no representative
hamr yes representative Hamlet yes
representative Mirad yeah representative
Bay no representative
Brennan no representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes and
representative Raptor yes and
representative Barry chair votes yes
that is 16 to4 and another election law
first um the uh the bill will be
reported out as ought to pass as amended
on 16 to4 I assume this well this can't
go on cuz it counters too many negatives
uh representative Lane who will be who
unless you want to not object to a
consent calendar I'm I'm happy to not
object to it but okay see I look forward
to you report about why towns should do
the $2 uh and I will uh I will stand up
for the towns and tell them they don't
have to take the $2 and we can have a
good laugh on it um and I look forward
to the vigorous debate on the floor of
the house um with that I will close the
executive session on House Bill
116 um scratch it off my list so there
will be yeah there will be a Minority
Report because it is not going on the it
has to have a Minority Report if it
doesn't go on the consent calendar and
you don't want me writing The Minority
Report because I I would thoroughly
probably enjoy it um these two dolls
this unfunded mandate
um all right um we're almost we're
getting done here um
you want to do oh represent L do you
have your portal amendment I do all
right let's do you want to distribute
that real fast to the uh I'm going to
open up the house executive session on
House Bill
463 um which
is uh EST the relative to the
establishment of an election law portal
um is there a
motion um she OTP right no she hasn't
well I just asked for the motion so
somebody has to make
a motion o2p uh to pass okay is there a
second second seconded by representative
Brennan is are there any amendments to
House Bill
463 yes yes representative Lan would you
like to present your Amendment um yes
two it's 2023 uh- 2385 and the right
hand side of the room has not yet
received it so I'll send it along line
representative um Lane um moves 8 house
bill
23 2385 H to house before 63 is there a
second to take up discussion second
there is a second we are now on
discussion of the Amendments
representative Lane um would you like to
explain the amendment um sure I'll wait
till everybody's got a copy um
uh what we have come to agree to is um
the portal bill that we passed last year
essentially with the
changes um that came up in the
conference committee um we've taken out
theava funding and uh then we've also
made it so that um applications um in
the election voter new voter
applications in the portal shall not
allow verification of identity age or
domicile by affidavit under
65412 and that's because they can still
go into the affidavit
um in person with the clerk or on the
same day but not there's no way to get a
sworn affidavit um and through a portal
there's nobody to take the sworn
affidavit we are allowing however the
verification of the citizenship by a
sworn because most the documentation for
citizenship is expensive it's very takes
a very long time to get and virtually no
state that we're aware of that has a
portal requires that and so we will
allow verification under a sworn
statement under perjury so um and that's
it I'll be happy to take questions
before we do that I'll give you my my
opening salvable on this I want to thank
the ranking member uh for accommodating
our concerns um I did look into the um
sworn statement about citizenship it
does appear to be a federal requirement
um so unless we were to bifurcate our um
ballots and our lists um it can't not
it's double negative um it has to take a
sworn statement um in order for us to be
in compliance that's what we currently
do we currently take a sworn statement
um for citizenship only um and then
everything else is handled by affidavit
so I do appreciate the ranking member uh
leave bringing in the affidavits for age
identity and doile um I have I had
assuming we don't adopt this amendment
um
what I believe are very legitimate
concerns about taking a quote unquote
sorn statement over the Internet with no
ID um there's software out there that is
free to use such as Microsoft power
automate where somebody could submit
probably anywhere from you know anywhere
from 15 to 20 voter registrations a
minute um if there was an affidavit like
system for identification age and
domicile um
these this committee knows my feelings
on affidavits in general um at least
when they're in person there's somebody
standing in front of you um when it goes
behind a computer screen and there's no
one there period there's nothing and
it's just click a button I am who I say
I am I swear it I swear it that is I
would hope both sides could see ripe for
abuse so I do appreciate the ranking
member bringing this amendment forward I
will be supporting the amendment um and
as soon the amendment passes most likely
the underlying bill um but I want to
thank the ranking member who was um a
lot of work talking and um went into
this so thank you sir thank you very
much representative M yes thank you Mr
chair uh question it says a completed
new voter voter application but then the
new voter application shall not allow
verification of age
domicile by affidavit Etc verification
citizen shall not be so how can you
complete a new voter
application without the some of the
information in Roman numeral
two I think to speak for repr two would
apply to
one a new application to the electronic
opponent shall not allow verification of
identity age or doile you can't really
do a I mean well it it's two two applies
to they're different sections so one and
two are linked and two defines what you
can do in section A of
one this this is the way that OSS
suggested that I drafted I had drafted
it somewhat differently um at the
beginning and this is the way they
suggested drafting it um because a got
very complicated the way that I wrote it
originally and and and and watch this
one representative Lane is it your
intention in the legislative process to
have section two be applying to section
1A yes would that be your legislative
intent that is my legislative intent
excellent further question uh further uh
comments on the
amendment hearing none uh I can't
believe there's no this is so small uh
clerk will call the role representative
bom yes representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative qualey yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative cutab yes representative
lean yes representative Ward yes
representative Hammer yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
Raptor yes representative Barry yes uh
and with that Amendment 2023 2385 H is
adopted to House Bill
463 the motion is now ought to pass as
amended we are on discussion on the bill
as amended is there discussion on the
bill as
amended I am stunned we're this is going
to be a record this is going to be our
first portal bill with no discussion
congratulations representative Lane you
have done it the clerk will call the
role representative Bo yes
representative prom O'Brien yes
representative quae yes representative
Ankerberg yes Representative burnam
no Representative warry no
representative wood no representative
Osborne yes Representative kab
no representa lanee
yes representative Ward yes
representative HR yes representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes representative Barry yes 16 16
to four with that um House Bill 463 will
be reported out to pass as amended 16
to4 uh who will be responsible for the
Minority
Report representative wood will do the
Minority Report um uh Lane let's work
together on the major on the majority
report okay um because I want to make
sure
it's agreeable across the board because
Lord knows this one has been a
contentious one um scratch this off of
our list congratulations to everybody
who's worked on that one by the way I
know that's been a long time coming
345 I'm going to close the executive
session on house
463 and that was 16 to four correct
Madam clerk y yeah otpa
okay um all right so now we're on to
kind of the last ones which have all
been paired up together um so let's take
up House Bill
345 FN enabling rank Choice voting for
State primary elections and municip po
elections um I need 345 uh
representative qua do you have a
motion yes thank you Mr chairman I move
that the committee find HP 345
inexpedient to legislate is there a
second I second representative wey
seconds I am sure there will be
discussion on the bill so let's get this
one
going okay yes Mr chair thank you yes
yes representative H um so House Bill
three 3
45 um we have an amendment I'd like to
do introduce an amendment but the
amendment had some errors that we're
having corrected right now by OS okay so
I don't have um in the entrance of um
working together here I will recess
345 thank um because there's but there
is a motion so can Madam clerk um
indicate the motion okay perfect there's
a motion when take it back up so I'm
recessing House Bill
um uh is there representative Hamlet do
you have any other amendments or any
other bills we should be aware of so we
get the Motions right and don't have to
vote unvote and vote
again well I have an amendment on house
bille 115 okay and what about 350 and
350 um yes okay so let's do 350 first uh
so I'll open up the executive session on
house B 350 relative to rank choice of
voting um since you have an amendment um
representative Hamlet I will recognize
you
first thank you Mr chair could you
please recognize Heath Howard to
introduce the amendment uh well first we
have to get a motion um oh sorry uh I
move a to pass on House Bill 350 as
amended and uh we so we have an we have
an OTP motion uh to help the
representative we have an O you're
making an a to pass motion correct yes
uh and I believe representative Howard
will probably second that would be my
guess um so now we are on uh the motion
is ought to pass um and I believe there
is an amendment representative Howard
you like to move an amendment yes I
would like to introduce uh
2023-24
77h okay is there a second to that
Amendment um and second second
representative Hamlet seconds let's give
every the committee a second to get a
hold of this
amendment because it is amendment paloa
day here at election law uh sorry it's a
2377 H if you guys do not have
it
okay
okay oh I'm sorry represent still still
handing them
out just to reiterate representative
Howard you said 2377 H correct that is
correct thank you just so we're okay I
think everybody's got it representative
Howard would like to speak to um
representative Hamlet's Amendment yeah
of course uh so this this amendment uh
would enable rank Choice voting in
primaries for specific races including
the governor or federal Congressional
offices at such as cd1 cd2 and US
Senate uh this bill would allow for uh
people to rank their preference as to
who they would prefer to uh hold those
offices uh come primary day uh and um
sorry I was uh my my laptop froze and
I'm not able to get my notes
so uh I apologies but I if uh
representative Hamlet would uh be
willing to kind of take it away from
here
sorry all right um yes so House Bill
three um the amendment to House Bill 350
this amendment 2377 is actually not an
enabling bill it's uh this is a bill
that would limit rank Choice voting to
just the
uh governor and federal Congressional
offices
um okay so that's all I really have
prepared to to say on that one okay is
there um discuss further discussion on
the
amendment okay hearing none I'm going to
have the clerk call the role on House
Bill 2020 sorry excuse me Amendment 2023
2377 H the clerk will read the role
perfect good timing representative osbor
representative boom
no representative Pome O'Brien no
Representative quae no representative
Ankerberg no representative Burnham no
Representative warry no representative
wood no representative Osborne nope
Representative kutab no representative
lean yes representative Ward yes
Representative hamr
no representative Hamlet yes
representative Mirad yeah representative
Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
Raptor yes and representative Barry no
so with that the uh committee fails to
adopt the amendment we are back on to
the motion of oop pass on HB 350 um is
there discussion on the
bill hearing none the clerk sure
everybody's here the clerk will call the
role representative Barry uh know I go
last oh sorry representative bom
no representative Pome O'Brien no
Representative quae no representative
Ankerberg no representative Burnham no
representative warry no representative
wood no representative Osborne no
Representative cutab no representative
Lane
yes representative Ward
yes representative
Hammer no representative hamblet yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay no representative Brennan no
representative Grill no representative
Howard yes representative Rapter yes and
representative Barry
no that is a no dog and it
is
three 6 to
14 they will write of this day in
election law for years to come I don't
even think I can type anything other
than 10 10 or 20 oh so it's just my
brains uh with that uh House Bill 350
will reported out as inexpedient to
legislate I'm sorry that the motion of
ought to pass to
now we is there another motion I
apologize representative qua you
recognized uh yes Mr chairman I move
that the committee
find HB 350 in expedient to legislate is
there a second second representative wey
seconds is there discussion on the
motion of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill
350 God to love Mason's rules um with
that hearing no discussion uh the house
the clerk will call the role for the
motion of inexpedient to legislate on
house B 350 representative Bo yes
representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative qua yes representative
Ankerberg yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osborne yes
representative cutab yes representative
lean no representative Ward no
representative
HR yes representative hamblet yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative Brennan yes
representative Grill yes representative
Howard
no did you let's let's uh finish the
role and then I will indulge the member
from
Handover I will I will adult the but
let's finish the role let the clerk
finish the role will
no representative Barry we are on the
motion of itl so I will be voting yes um
and I will indul if without objection I
will indulge the member from Handover to
change his
vote you vent the can you say that into
the mic for me thank you I wanted to
really thank you uh first of all and say
that I vote I meant to vote no yes um
okay Mr chair yes I apologize I vote
voted the wrong way too I meant well I
guess I guess if we're doing it for
everyone we'll do it for no I'm just kid
it's fine without objection without
objection okay without objection I'll
will allow the members to change their
vote um vote no and now the clerk will
read the results of
the vote that was totally ordinary we're
having a great time on Election Day you
know when they uh when they do the
trainings for chairs next year they're
not going to use today as the as the
template they're not going to use
today that is
14-6 14 to6 that sounds about right um
for inexpedient to legislate uh who will
be responsible for the majority report
representative qua would be responsible
for the majority report representative
Hamlet would you like to take the
Minority Report I'm going to give it to
representative Mirad as
punishment okay okay
knows it the beautiful part is I get to
change it after you send it to me so who
really knows what it'll say um okay with
that I will close the House Executive
the
executive uh session on House Bill
350 um representative handl that we're
still waiting on two on 345 correct the
amendment okay so with we only got two
left so we're getting there y'all um the
uh with my parents being here today I
felt it was appro to drop a y'all in
there you haven't heard that from me
before um going to open up the uh House
Executive session on House Bill
115 uh which I believe I'm going to move
to ought to pass cuz I have an amendment
uh oh actually no uh representative B
you want to go you want to do the uh the
ought to pass motion first yes all right
there's a rep U representative bone
moves ought to pass I will go ahead and
second it representative bone do you
have an amendment yeah I have an
amendment number
22708 uh again go ahead and hit that for
me again representative sorry yes I have
Amendment
2270 H all right is there a second for
the representative Bon's amendment to
take up the amendment
representative weary indicates he's
going to Second uh we are now on
discussion of sorry we are now on
discussion of amendment 2023 2020 2270 H
to House Bill
115 uh we are on discussion of the
amendment right okay this
amendment changes the primary date until
the 3 Tuesday in
August which is the only change that
could be affected for the 2024
election okay everything else stays the
same with this with this amendment the
June date cannot be done on the 2024
election because that would move the
filing for example to a I mean to March
and the bill probably won't even be
passed by then so and and this and thing
but the the secretary of state has
testified when we first brought this up
they would like the in August we have a
problem with the 45 day federal law
thing with the existing schedule in
September and and that could be a
problem if we have to have a
recount uh also affidavit voting also
military voting it gives them another
couple of weeks three weeks to to get
their balance in so with that I'm going
the end because it's the my main point
of doing this is the only change that
can be done for the 2024 election so
that further discussion on the
amendment uh yes representative P
O'Brian thank you uh this would make
this uh primary fall on my birthday some
years one year some people may think
that's a good thing to be at the polls
on their birthday or a bad thing maybe
that's a bad thing I I'm fine with it
either way um I don't really
care
but August is a good yes bring me a cake
August is um a good time for the primary
I think for college students that are
getting prepared to go to college they
can um be sure that they vote before
they get there and they don't have to
worry about it so we hear a lot of about
college students and their interest in
voting and they can either Vote or sign
up prior to this a little earlier and
get the um absentee ballot sent to them
if they happen to be um out of state but
but it's not as likely that they'll be
out of state so I think this is good for
the uh college students further
discussion on the
amendment representative Bay I just like
to take some levity uh my daughter goes
to School in Hawaii she leaves home as
early as
July sounds like June would work great
for her
um uh further discussion on the
amendment um I will be opposing this
amendment um two reasons the first of
which is as you guys know I'm I'm very
outcome oriented and um our friend in
the corner office has already vetoed
August has already said he'll veto
August again um so I don't see any point
of spinning my way wheels in the mud um
number two I actually don't I have voted
for August in the past um before our
friend in the corner office gave us his
opinion um and I'm not a huge fan of
August um parents are still out of town
for the most part and as a new dad
that's I'm a little more sensitive to
that now than I used to be but now I
kind of really get it um especially when
you need that vacation um I I am a I've
said it before I said it again I'm a
June man I'm going to stay a June man um
and it's okay that we can uh we can
respectfully disagree but I do think um
June kind of hits everything which is uh
you know there's nothing going on in
June which is why it's actually a great
time to conduct a primary because
there's nothing going on um versus
August parents are still out of town and
um I know I just feel like I'm uh I'm
gonna I'm going to bring it home I ran
as the parents candidate and I'm gonna
I'm going to stick up for parents and
let him vote in June instead of
August representative bone you can tell
me why I'm wrong thank you there's a lot
going on in June the school graduation
all all through the month uh and that
that's a big issue parents are getting
the kids ready to go to Camp so there a
lot going on in June more than and my
main point too for the August this time
around is if you do june that can't be
effective until 20
26 uh because the filing would have to
be like in in March this way leaves
everything everything the same yeah
there still while in June you have you
know three weeks less of campaigning
which is good and it and we don't have
in June for example can you I go to the
gym a lot of times during the week and
you got all these TV screens in front of
me in front of you and it's bad enough
from September to June I mean SE to
November watching all the political
ads uh on all the screens and imagine
doing that from June until November
watching all the political ads uh which
hurts local local ads because I remember
people complaining they can't put their
ads on TV because of all the political
ads and it's only a set time for ads
that TV stations can do because they
have to show their shows so anyway
that's why I'm I've been against youing
from the very beginning thank you
representative
Lane uh thank you I would like to agree
with representative B that there is a
lot going on in June for instance we'll
still be in session so we will be both
campaigning during session and we will
be doing this work and um for the
illustrious uh salary of $100 a year and
I think that asking a lot of people um
particularly even those in leadership so
for that reason I will be voting for uh
representative B's August Bill thank
you other comments on the
bill all right with that the clerk will
call the
role um and this is for the amendment
227 Z yes we are on the vote on the
amendment
yeah oh yes representative pom o Brian
yes Representative quae no
representative Ankerberg no
representative
brunham
yes representative wary yes
representative wood yes representative
Osborne no representative cutab
yes representative Lane
yes representative Ward
no representative hamr yes
representative hamblet
yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard
yes representative rafter yes
representative Barry no with that uh
Amendment what was the number 15 to 5 15
to five Amendment 2023 22
[Music]
70 uh is uh added to House Bill 115 we
are now on a to pass as amendment is
there discussion on the
bill there uh there's an amendment that
I'd like to uh
propose okay uh I don't believe we can
adopt two amendments if they compete is
that correct we can okay we can't adopt
two
amendments the second is prevailing
correct the SEC uh that's a great
question does anybody know it looks like
yes it looks like the second would be
prevailing
okay U do you have an amendment
number uh
2370 so not
2270 which we just looked at
2370 however this get confusing is there
a
second uh seconded by represent
Hamlet it is once again this is not
going to be the day that they use as the
example for how committee work is
normally
handled this is a good day of weird
things happening recessing coming in and
out no it does it's it's added the
last chary yes it would be a June any
more of
these I
didn't
okay uh we've got to move in second to
Amendment 223
2378 represent Howard you moved this
amendment correct that's correct okay
would you like to speak to to your
motion sure uh so thank you Mr chairman
and thank you fellow committee members
uh this amendment does change the
original back Bill back to a June
primary uh to be clear uh but in
addition it would also add the ability
for the State uh to hold its primaries
as a rank Choice eligible uh system if
the party wants to opt in uh this would
only be for the races of governor and
Federal Congressional offices so that'd
be cd2 cd1 uh and US
Senate this uh is a bill that I think
works for both sides uh of of the aisle
uh because a it gets rank Choice voting
which is something that there are
factions on both sides that do agree
with it as well as uh it gets a June
primary which I do agree there are some
advantages of making a uh Stronger
cohesive uh party when uh you're running
at a top ticket level like governor and
Congressional races so it makes a lot of
sense to uh to allow for that party
unity and have a more in-depth uh
general election
process uh as for how this process uh
would affect the general population I
think that it would be a good test to
see whether or not rank Choice voting
could be adopted further or if we should
uh yeah that's correct sorry uh but it
would allow for uh the ability to test
out rank Choice voting in a smaller
setting that would not necessarily have
the implications that uh would allow for
longer uh election run times if we had
lower ballot races uh available so this
is kind of a good happy medium uh I
think as a starting point for rank
Choice voting uh and yeah thank you
further discussion representative haml
thank you Mr chairman I do have some
comments um so the basic premise is that
a candidate in a multi-candidate
race must win over 50% of the total
votes in their
race okay so it assures that no
candidate can win with a small
percentage of the votes it is fully
constitutional and better represents the
will of the voters than the first pass
the post system that we use
now um rank Choice voting is also
quicker and cheaper than runoff
elections and has proven to result in
better voter
turnout um a party nominee who wins with
a higher percentage of the primary votes
will be a stronger general election
candidate for the party than a Nomine
who only received a low percentage of
the votes rank Choice voting is actually
PR Liberty because it gives voters more
choices in the candidates they vote for
and I would like to point out two things
at the very on page six of the
amendment uh number 19 effective date
the effective date for the rank Choice
voting portion of this amendment or of
this amendment is January 1st
20126 the effective date of of um you
know changing changing the primary to
June would be 60 days after we
passed the the
bill
than okay uh further discussion
representative bone yes thank you Mr
chair we just passed an amendment 15 to
five to change the
date to August now we have another
amendment to change the date back to
June
um I think probably this amendment that
we have would leave what we had and not
change the date back so I have a problem
with is this correct we you know we have
how many amendments are we going to have
to keep changing the date back and forth
we changed the date to August now we're
trying to change it back to June so can
I make another amendment to change it
back to August I mean this is getting
we should is that is that a question is
that a question of the chair or just a
rhetorical rical question yes
representative katab I'm not sure that
um per current statue the effective date
uh on this statue would be legal it
would be in um conflict with RSA 14
colon
9-a um part 2 G where it says that it
gives a list of the requirements for
effective dates and then you get down to
the part where all other laws shall take
effect 60 days after passage um the only
law where you can do January 1st
following passage is affecting judicial
practice and procedure or establishing
or eliminating criminal prohibition
civil causes of actions or remedies or
limitations of actions um so I just I
don't I don't think this would be in
conflict with our our statute for the
effective date so there's a principle in
uh
legislative process uh one legislator
can one legislature cannot bind the
hands of a future legislature so the
fact that the bill explicitly States the
dates would override because new laws
override old laws right so it's kind of
irrelevant that it's in Conflict it very
well may be but the the new the fact
that this bill states that date that
cannot be held hostage by an older
legisl
legislator legislative body which is
obviously not so that that point I
believe would be moot because it
explicitly says it now if it didn't say
it I think you would have a point but it
does actually explicitly say it um that
being said I'm going to support this um
I am not a fan of rank Choice voting
I've given many many speeches about why
I don't like rank Choice voting but I
have also said another thing which is
I'll do darn or anything to get to June
um so um I will do darn or anything to
get to June and I appreciate
representative ham working with me on
that so you're going to see something
you'll probably never see me do again uh
which is vote for rank Choice voting
because I love me some June um and I
hope others will join me who also may
like June um and I think this was a good
kind of Common Ground you also can't do
rank Choice voting without moving the
primary date probably realistically to
June um because you're not going to get
those results um very quickly and that's
that's a oh representative uh the clerk
is here to tell me what I've done
entirely wrong is he's Mr clerk do you
want
to um should I recess and Co chat all
right let me go and figure out what I've
done wrong I'll be uh recess for 5
minutes
we're going to come back into order I'm
going to reopen the executive session
for the house election law committee um
after consultation with um the clerk who
called the speaker the speaker has
ruled Amendment 2023 2370 H is non-
gerain to the underlying bill um I do
just for what it's worth um I I I
disagree but that's not my decision um
it is ultimately the speaker's decision
so um we are going to have to pull the
amendment back uh because it is non
gerain to the underlying bill um so we
are back on the ought to pass Amendment
ought to pass as amended um with
Amendment Ralph what I representative M
excuse me what's your Amendment 227 2270
H 2270 h uh so we are on to discussion
on the bill as amended by
22708 so there discussion on the
bill okay uh yes no maybe so look like
you want to no okay um uh I I'll be
voting against this uh there's no point
in sending over an August bill that's
going to get vetoed um I do believe
there will be legislation coming forward
from our friends across the wall uh to
get something done on this matter that
may actually be called to into law but I
don't as I said earlier I don't believe
in spinning my wheels in the mud um and
I definitely don't want to create more
work for us on veto day so with that the
clerk shall call the
role representative boom yes
representative Pome O'Brien yes
Representative quy no representative
Ankerberg no representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes yes representative
Osborne no representative kutab yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward no representative hamr yes
representative Hamlet yes representative
Mirad yes representative Bay yes
representative Brennan
no representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
Raptor no and representative Barry
no oh
God it's still 101 no it's not 101
there's no way 13 to
S they will I'm telling you they're
going to write a book about today's day
in election law I swear to God uh so
with that um that'll be passed out as
ought to pass as amended representative
bone you will be responsible for the
committee report um who's going to do
the minority yep I'm going to figure
that out um I think you should write it
I really I I want to write the committee
the amendment The Minority Report but
it's I'm the chairman and it's usually
inappropriate to write The Minority
Report when you are the chair of the
committee I I can I can write it um I'm
just it's inappropriate to write it um
so I need to find someone else who can
write it um representative Osborne would
you mind writing The Minority Report for
us I I am I am sure you
would um okay uh and with that we only
have one other bill
I'm going to close executive session on
House Bill
115 and we are almost there folks that
was 13 to 7 yeah
geeez think Junes is not meant to be let
a man let a man dream let me
dream um yeah everybody the weather in
June is so lovely just the
bill
dream um okay um we are now on to the
last bill of the day thank God uh House
Bill
345 FN enabling rank Choice voting for
State primary elections and Municipal
elections uh I believe they're repres
you have an amendment correct okay so I
just want to make sure I'm get the right
motion right so can you make
representative H can you please make a
motion of a to pass I move a to pass is
there a
second Bill 345 don't we have a I'm we
already have a motion you are correct we
have a motion okay an itl so um oh we
have an we an itl an itl motion was made
that is correct we are we are on an itl
motion I forgot we'd already taken this
up we haven't voted yet and there's no
amendments because it's an ital motion
um so what I think we need to do um so
we can do one of two things we can
withdraw the motion of itl which is
probably what I would recommend for the
committee so that we can honor each
other's amendments um because that's
that's a good way to work together right
um and then we can come back to an itl
motion should it be necessary so I
believe representative qu I believe you
made the itl motion correct would you be
willing to withdraw your itl motion I'm
sure what the implications of that uh
the implications of that are it allows
us to take up representative Hamlet's
Amendment um because if we're on an itl
motion we can't take up an amendment and
so if I withdraw what happens next uh
well I would allow representative Hamlet
to make her ought to pass motion and
then bring forward her Amendment um and
then we can vote her Amendment up or
down and then it'll be on an aop pass as
amended or not um and if that fails then
it would go back to an itl motion which
would be where I imagine it would end
up you do not have to do that we can
take the itel motion now if you would
like it is I'm not you can't force you
to withdraw it of course you can but
you're recommending that I withdraw it
uh I'm I'm recommending for you
respecting your colleague's work um that
we allow her to bring her Amendment
forward as a courtesy I will withdraw
the motion okay so so we are we have no
motion now we are on back on an not to
pass motion from represent Hamlet
correct yes and then there's a
second for her motion of oop pass
representative Howard seconds the motion
representative Hamlet do you have an
amendment to House Bill
345 I I do have an amendment but it's
been corrected by OS and it should be
down here any
minute okay
um it's I'm going to recess for 60
seconds while I confer with the ranking
member
okay
how
transparent
back we are back we have the amendment
um
um uh representative
Hamlet
uh representative Hamet would you like
to introduce your Amendment yes thank
you Mr
chair so um Amendment it's amendment
number 2023
23978 and representative Howard do you
second the adoption of
amendment uh yes I will H you may speak
to your Amendment thank you okay so this
is an amendment to House Bill 345 House
Bill 345 is an enabling bill for rank
Choice voting it would allow State
political parties to use rank Choice
voting for party primaries if they
choose to it would also allow cities and
towns to use rank Choice voting for
Municipal elections if they choose to
and House Bill 345 explains the terms
and procedures used in rank Choice
voting elections
however since rank Choice voting is
still a New Concept in New Hampshire I
am introducing this amendment to limit
rank Choice voting to just Municipal
elections although rank Choice voting
would be extremely useful in state party
primaries political parties would not be
allowed to use rank Choice voting unless
approved by another bill or if we pass
House Bill 345 without this
amendment uh use of rank Choice voting
is expanding all over this country uh it
is a voting system that expands the
ability for voters to have their voices
heard it is easy to use and easy to
count some municipalities effectively
have runoff elections in their Municipal
elections the use of rank Choice voting
could save them time and money with
better
turnout and because we are a Dylan rule
state they cannot use rank Choice voting
unless we pass House Bill 345 in order
to
enable municipalities to use rank choice
or to choose rank Choice voting for
themselves some municipalities will opt
in some won't it should be up to them
and their voters um training will be
available to any cities and towns and
citizens that seek help with
implementation if you believe that rank
Choice voting is fully constitutional
uh as many courts have found then vote
to let cities and towns try it if you
believe that rank Choice voting
eliminates vote splitting and the
spoiler effect then vote to let cities
and towns try it if you believe that
rank Choice voting is fairer then first
pass the post and better represents the
will of the voters then vote to let
cities and towns try it rank Choice
voting is a pro-liberty voting
system
I can explain further if you have any
questions uh further statements or
questions from the committee on
Amendment 2023
239 please limit your conversations to
the amendment yes res of Howard thank
you Mr chairman and fellow committee
members uh the amendment to HB 345
really does allow municipalities to
lower their costs significantly I think
that the Manchester Mayoral race is a
very good example of what we have now
versus what it could potentially be uh
we had four candidates running uh in the
Manchester race that have already gone
through that uh primary stage and we're
now in their general election that's
basically a runoff we could instead
limit that to one election day rather
than two which is a huge uh way to save
money uh and on top of that it's
something where we are not necessarily
forcing the towns and municipalities to
up take this but just giving them
additional opportunities to choose the
best way forward for themselves thank
you further comments on the amendment
representative weie uh just a question
does this um provide
for
the publication or the the uh revelation
of the outcomes of each
subsequent uh kind of rank Choice runoff
in other words do you do you are you
able to understand the progression
through the voting of the algorithm are
to rephrase your question are you asking
is there a public information campaign
attached to this no no that was not the
question the question has to do with the
the results of you know theoretically
the rank Choice voting goes through a
series of runoffs bya the rank Choice
algorithm and then so the question is is
what are the results of each uh tier in
the in the in the algorithm is that made
known so that you can see okay this
didn't get first P the post or whatever
it is and and then you know does it
account for you know attrition due to
people not completing all the rankings
for the number of runoffs that occur etc
etc so I I just want to understand if
people have transparency to what they're
actually doing because you know it
sounds great but I but if there's not
any
transparency as to what actually
happened during the voting and the
algorithm that rank Choice voting you
know enabled the final outcome then then
it's I object to this representative
Hamlet would you like to answer the
question yes thank you Mr chair yes it's
fully
transparent
um the results are fully documented in
each round of the voting in an easy to
understand fashion and everything is
replicable so yes it's done openly and
it's completely transparent and it's
replicable further questions comments on
the
amendment representative
qu thank you Mr chairman it'll be no
surprised that since I oppose
the original bill that I also oppose
this amendment given its slight change
from the original bill I do respect the
uh I I I appreciate the interest in
improving things on the part of the the
people working on this but I just don't
agree it'll be an improvement I think
it'll be a
mistake and my concerns revolve
explicitly around questions of
transparency and
impartiality uh I I approached this
whole question from the standpoint of
of the the purpose of our election
system that ultimate purpose I think we
all agree that the legitimacy of our
entire system of governments local state
federal depends upon the consent of the
government and the purpose of Elections
is to ensure we have the consent of the
government and as I see it in order to
fulfill that purpose our election system
has to perform an accurate assessment of
public sentiment on the the questions
and candidates it issue and it has to do
so in such a way that we preserve the
trust and faith of the
public that the outcomes of these these
elections are are
valid and my focus is on that latter
part preserving the trust of the public
it's
essential uh and to me preserving the
Trust of the public requires that our
election processes be
transparent that they be
impartial and also that they produce an
unambiguous uh victure in a timely
fashion and as I said a moment ago my
emphas my focus here is
on transparency and impartiality
regarding
transparency our current system of uh PL
plurality wins the the issue wins the
election uh by by transparency I mean
that the public can readily understand
the processes they don't even have to
study them that would be ideal and in
this case with pluralities we have that
circumstance the pl plurality approach
to determining a winner can be reduced
to a three-word algorithm most votes
wins what's proposed in this bill and
the amendment that we're discussing
now it's four pages of explanation
required in the bill to to educate
people on how it
works uh page and a half of that like 52
lines or I think I counted them 17
definitions which people would need to
understand to fully understand the
results as calculated by this
method
uh and I think that is way too high a
burden I think that is a a significant
DEC increase in
transparency it's particularly when
people on their own wish to check for
themselves the result under our present
system all you need to do is look at the
vote totals there's no math required to
Simply compare the vote totals for the
different issues or candidates and you
know the result you've validated it that
is very
transparent in my view this change
that's being proposed would be a very
serious decrease in transparency and
such a decrease in transparency that to
me it is a fatal defect in the
approach another aspect I'm concerned
with has to do with
impartiality the
proponents uh I've read the literature
from the proponents of this approach and
they
explicitly present as a benefit that the
system will then
reward candidates who have a broader
appeal to the electorate that's how they
that's how they phrase I'm paraphrasing
but that's the gist of
it uh it's not up to the election system
to reward
candidates for any basis whatsoever
that's up to the
voters the election system needs to be
strictly impartial with respect to
candidates another example of uh
decreased impartiality or lack of
impartiality comes to another
uh effect of RCV uh which is s as a
benefit which is it reduces the influ
influence of uh what the proponents in
the literature I've read it was handed
out to us at previous election law
committee meetings they refer to a
spoiler
candidates uh I didn't see a definition
but from the examples given I presume
that that means candidates that re
receive low vote
totals well again it's not up to the
election system to reduce the influence
of particular candidates on the outcome
of an election whatsoever that is
strictly a function of the
voters uh so I consider that another
fatal defect in terms of
impartiality uh with respect to this
particular bill that has opt in for
Municipal elections it's my view that
all voters all citizens have the same
rights and they all have the same right
to transparency and impartiality in
their election system if we adopted this
I believe that residents of some
municipalities that chose to adopt it
would be subject to a lessened exercise
of those rights and for those reasons I
do oppose this amendment okay uh further
discussion uh and I believe uh just for
the sake of uh time I believe everybody
we've we've debated um discussed RCV to
extent so I'm going to ask members
to be brief going forward because I
think there are some members who were
trying toart representative Howard yes
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
address some of uh representative quay's
concerns uh first of all I just wanted
to say uh that when it comes to the
consent of the governor of the Govern
when we are selecting somebody to be a
representative that is trying to get a
majority of people voting and if you can
get a majority of people over 50% in
your community to approve you then you
are meeting that consent and that's what
uh rank Choice voting helps do because
instead of having to lock people into
Party politics allows them to vote their
conscience and I mean a lot of the time
and when we have these Municipal races
they're nonpartisan to begin with uh so
it's uh you know not necessarily trying
to benefit one party or the other it's
just trying to allow for the greatest
ability to come to a consensus amongst a
group of people for instance I know that
we mentioned first past the post let's
take an election that say has 10
candidates to make it easy all of them
get about 10% of the vote one candidate
gets 11% of the vote and one candidate
gets nine the candidate with 11% of the
vote would end up winning the
election 90% up up nearly 90% of people
didn't vote for the for that person and
we're going to say that that's
acceptable I don't think that that's
consent of the Govern I think that when
we are talking about the system that we
have right now we're thinking about it
in terms of it works for me it's
comfortable but it doesn't always
necessarily work best for the people and
that's what rank Choice voting is
seeking to fix because it's not just
saying if there are too many candidates
then the pool is so diluted that you
know whoever you end up voting for could
end up winning with a minimal percentage
such as
11% and that is why rank Choice voting
is superior to first pass the post thank
you thank you uh I'm the clerk I'm going
to end executive session on the
amendment and the clerk will call the
role I don't believe we're going to move
any F farther forward representative
B no representative Pome O'Brien
no Representative quy no representative
Ankerberg no representative Burnham no
Representative warry no rep
representative wood
no representative Osborne NOP
Representative cutab no representative
Lan yes representative Ward yes
representative Hammer
no representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yes
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan yes representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rter yes and representative Barry uh no
uh with that uh Amendment 2023
2397 um is failed to adopt we are back
on the motion of ought to pass uh I
believe debate on the underlying
Amendment which failed was probably
sufficient and without objection the
clerk will call the role on the motion
of ought to pass on House Bill 345
FN repres representative bom no
representative Pome O'Brien no
representative qua no representative
Ankerberg no representative Burnham no
Representative warry no representative
wood no representative Osborne no
Representative cutab no representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
Representative hamr no representative
Hamlet yes representative Mirad yeah
representative Bay yes representative
Brennan no representative Grill yes
representative Howard yes representative
rapor yes and representative Barry no
um 12 it's on a on a vote of 8 to 12 the
aop pass motion fails representative
quale you recognized to make a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move
that HB 345 be found inexpedient to
legislate is there a second M chairman
I'd like representative we seconds
hearing no debate the clerk will call
the
role representative boom
yes representative Pome O'Brien yes
representative qua yes representative
ber yes representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Osbourne yes
representative cutab yes representative
Lan no representative Ward no
representative hamr yes representative
Hamlet no representative Mirad no
representative Bay no representative
Brennan
yes representative Grill no
representative Howard no representative
Raptor no representative Barry yes and
on a
shocking 12 to on a shocking 12 to eight
vote the motion of inexpedient to
legislate passes um representative qua
you'll be responsible for the majority
report um representative how would you
like to do The Minority Report since I
already gave one to representative
Hamlet sure um with no other bills on
the uh correct we've handled all the
bills today just going to trust but
verify this yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes I was no other
bills on the executive session notice
for today I'm going to close today's
meeting of the House Executive session I
look forward to seeing you all in
January thank you
guys